Negative 3 is correct, nice equation solving if you got that one correct. The
lowest common denominator for our fractions is 9x. We know x is already a factor
of 3x, so really we just need to find the LCD for 9 and 3x. When we use our
factor tree method we can see that we get a final product of 9x. And our first
fraction, the x terms cancel to 1, leaving us with 9 times 1 or 9. For our 2nd
fraction the factors of 9 canceled the 1 leaving us with -1 times x, or -x. And
finally for our last fraction 9 x divided by 3 x equals 3. So we're left with 4
times 3 which equals 12. Solving this linear equation will get a access equal to
-3. Remember, we just reverse the signs here, since negative x equals 3, so
positive x would equal negative 3. For this original equation, x cannot equal 0.
It's an excluded value. And since our answer was x equals negative 3, we're
okay. We can keep this as our solution set.